[Music]
Parliament is set to sign off on key
measures to get the EU to carbon
neutrality by 2050 they include a
tougher emissions trading system and end
to the sale of polluting vehicles and
rules to reduce waste and build a
circular economy
MEPS will vote on legislation to boost
Renewables in the eu's energy mix and
ensure buildings and infrastructure are
more energy efficient they will continue
to push for assistance for households
and businesses hit by high energy prices
and are backing a special fund to help
Europeans meet the cost of the green
transition
work will continue on a pact on
migration and Asylum MEPS want a fairer
more responsive system that protects
those in need while ensuring better
screening of new arrivals and improved
cooperation between EU countries
Parliament will have its final say on
rules ensuring our digital world is
fairer and safer for all members want a
common framework governing artificial
intelligence and how our data is shared
regulation of crypto assets to tackle
Financial crime and measures to
strengthen Europe's semiconductor
ecosystem and MEPS will set their
position on proposed rules for work
obtained via digital platforms the
so-called gig economy they want to
improve conditions for employees while
fostering the sector's growth
[Music]